[Music]
in a lazy gift news awesome submitted by
lack of somebody somebody her sugar
daddy dating website has released a
monthly subscription gift box for sugar
babies finally some value the sugar
babies are paying their money for the
subscription but sugar daddies my
painful okay this okay what's up with
the subscription box craze everybody
loves I don't know you don't have to
think and you don't know what you're
getting
yeah and it's usually [ __ ] you want yeah
what's your subscription box I don't
have one anymore but it used to be with
a birch box
what kind of birch box is that so birch
box is uh pretty much like a make up
sample box oh well like you just put in
your preferences like oh like what kind
of skin condition do you have do you
tend to go for colors or neutrals and
stuff like that and then they kind of
customize the box with like products
that they think that you might like
do you have epsy no I don't bite hurt
that one's really good love it see I had
it for like two and a half years I liked
loot crate when they sponsored us you
did yep oh I got a free couple loot
crate boxes in there but they don't
sponsor us anymore so I'll have any more
loot crate yeah they're all over there
like a collection of it do you have I
mean it sounds like this is Christian by
a boyfriend no I have a lot of
subscription boxes really do you have a
clothing one I have trunk club yeah yeah
yeah okay you guys found it yeah I trunk
club and then the hip C and then I used
to have one for nails before I did the
gels I had like the nail wraps they have
different designs every month and then I
have one for candles I tried the food
ones
there's fruit ones food ones like a blue
a praise oh yeah how is that [ __ ] cuz
you gotta cook it still right yeah and
then I cook it slower dude
I'm not jump like it takes forever cause
like the I gotta read the directions and
well you have to do it in the order of
the box and sometimes it's not the most
efficient that's exactly and the flavor
it's like I work so hard and then I go I
could [ __ ] cook something better than
this we did blue apron once and I loved
it so much I'm like we gotta get the
subscription
yeah because I don't cook like you I
understand cuz you actually like playing
with your food and creating things but
for me I have no imagination and I
create about a long display yeah see you
give me instructions giving ingredients
and I'll do it yeah that's why I like
baking better than cooking because
cooking it's like throw a little of this
and a little of that but I need to know
exactly how much goes in here I don't
know what a little bit of this tell me
step by step at me everything I don't
know what to do I love getting creative
IKEA where I buy like three different
furniture I just build what I want a
mega furniture yeah we don't have
working furniture but here's a lot of
fun oh yeah bunch of nails everywhere I
can do it with drinks I can make drinks
you can make a drink out of any yeah
like really freaking good
so one party trick yeah this
subscription box is by arrangement calm
which is a sugar daddy dating website
and they unveiled this new subscription
box word sugar daddies combined them for
their sugar babies and I'm gonna show
you guys a video should get a sugar
daddy I feel like if I had a sugar daddy
I just want money like I don't want to
guys what they want
I just want yeah but this is a
legitimate gifts alright they like it
it's not I'm just thinking I would just
ask you what do you want that's why we
got husbands
good luck you get black evil here at the
same time here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so these would work for the guy shoots
like aliens [ __ ] about what I'd love to
you do will be great if it's like
sleeping pills for him she's like
[Music]
I feel like the makers of this
subscription box are like five nerds
that have never had sex with women or or
been a sugar daddy or anything because
they think it's about this the sex the
girls don't want to have sex to get sex
items no sex so they can buy it by like
a car and shoes and like nails and like
get their you know [ __ ] done you don't
want more sex stuff with the guy that's
like something they have to do so that
they get what they want to get yeah this
is not good well then actually they're
smart because they're they're trying to
market it for the sugar daddies goodbye
I love how it's like now you could get
yourself a ball gag for your [ __ ]
girl so he's hopefully sends that with
an envelope full of cash
candy massage oil rock candy in a ball
gag can you play it again real quick and
we can hear the music because I swear to
god it's like it's like I worked a lot
of beats in my life they created that
video okay well I lose the music oh what
I mean like so this is a gift that they
can now buy for their hookers they're
not hookers or sugar baby
it's a consenting arrangement between
two adults and if it just so happens to
have sex involved that's separate or
romantic relationship but the
arrangement is for like two hanging out
right I guess yeah but why does it have
all these [ __ ] items that point to
hooker that's why I'm saying I think
they're marketing it for sugar daddy or
the guy because they want sex
$89 what the [ __ ] for 25 bucks a hundred
eighty-nine a month
for this [ __ ] though pretty much $200
for this yeah
that's horrible I don't know any girl
that will open that up and go oh my god
always weird there's not a single thing
here that I would want I do get it
though if they sent it over to her and
go like yeah now you don't have to buy
it when I come over but every month
she's expected by [ __ ] first of all
second of all she's like hey pay me in
Bitcoin [ __ ] like she doesn't have
that didn't do any of that [ __ ] hundred
percent guaranteed oh man I feel like we
could come up with a better gimme gimme
three three three items three items that
the girl would buy like I said sleepy
yeah you guys could make a snap box and
it would be so much more bomb I was in
general like I would buy a snack box no
for the sugarbabyz I will give them like
designer things or cosmetics or like
manicure pedicures right yeah coupon for
massage before I won't touch you for
three weeks
yes well you don't seem like this mattes
shit's real other than that it's a free
month where I pay you and I don't visit
you yeah or I can I can chill on my back
and I don't have to put my mouth on your
dick yeah because I can never quite tell
the one I'm putting my mouth if I'm
putting my mouth on your dick or your
lower gut yeah it's all sort of in the
same region like but their forehead
patches oh dude it does they get a get a
gut helmet oh yeah yeah dude needs
[ __ ] sash around that thing big okay
stop shaming these fat sugar daddies
okay
sorry sugar daddy thank you you should
cheer up out there I love you guys were
rich and lonely do you think you can see
yourselves being sugar daddies no I
would [ __ ] a robot poor lonely [ __ ] a
robot ha ha I would go hunting like a
cougar every night
and I'm [ __ ] robots if I was
desperate enough I would totally be a
sugar baby fun it depends on how rich I
am like if I'm super rich where I'm
traveling the world that I probably have
like sugar boobs all the world
like one in every country or whatever
because you're gonna have escort is not
what that cuz sugarbabyz I guess they're
the ones that just get gifts and money
and they get there why would you want to
sugar baby yeah it's all good wait guys
you build a relationship with them and
they're still your friends it's like a
subscription service for your girlfriend
basically yeah you're paying a certain
amount of monthly for companionship yeah
regular like that being like I wouldn't
even when you when you have a wife or
girlfriend as I buying a car right and
then if you get a hooker that's renting
a car but sometimes that rental doesn't
feel that good so you want something
else we lease a car and I think that's
where the sugar baby it's like you're at
least yes oh but for you when you get a
sugar baby it's for sex - yeah yeah is
the sex you that's the sugar baby I
would be good right everyone gets good
prizes I mean put it this way though
like pair of heels now and then let's
say you had a hooker binge for the last
ten years and you're kind of just bored
with sex like just sex without a you
know without anything behind this person
is just a hot girl right just sounds
like you're gonna start [ __ ] animals
at that point yeah you can go that way
or you can go the sugar baby route which
like you can pay for that experience of
pretend girlfriend oh it's like the
honeymoon phase all the time it's like
you've been [ __ ] hookers a long time
you even killed a hooker because you
thought maybe you'd feel something oh my
gosh and then one day you're like you
know what I'm we're trying to build a
relationship with somebody and what
better way to do that than having to pay
the monthly exactly I would probably do
that too then yeah so I'm like I don't
want to establish a whole [ __ ]
relationship like whatever I'm a
different place is cooled you're just my
played thing yeah you'll be assured it
was the buckle mama her cougar geriatric
those good women those shittiest names
yeah I know
Cougars nice it's like you're on the
prowl yeah yeah I wanna be a wildcat I
feel like I would want to be a Jaguar
though yeah boom yeah that's what about
a hyena they give a really bad laughs
you sound like a [ __ ] Mexican now you
know so what are guys doing whales
walruses we're Wallace hey guys thanks
for watching that last video make sure
to follow us on instagram @ JK films to
watch more videos
[Music]